and
tricks i open js
i just got everything ready i'm gonna
present
to you the best tips and tricks that you
hopefully can add to your day-to-day
of coding to have more fun be more
productive and efficient and
show off to your friends what else do
you tip some tricks
and maybe they learn something new too
i work on vs code so tips and tricks
talks
are a ton of fun for me as well because
i can blend in my personal favorites
that i
show off to everybody who cares to
listen
and i can go back to the recent release
notes
and get all the amazing work that the
team has done
in front of you so you can start using
them
and i can go all the way back kind of
beneath the surface
obvious code where a lot of amazing
features linger
that users haven't discovered yet so
i am happy this is my happy place
to show these tips and tricks to you
to get things started i mentioned you
can show these tips and tricks to others
so how can you best show that often
there's
keyboard shortcuts involved and commands
and all these little ui pieces one has
to uncover and explain how to get there
so the best way to give tips and tricks
is
a remember the command and
b if you know the command and use it
more often
learn the shortcut let's start with that
so when you want to demo something you
can enable screencast mode
you did that so now everything i do in
vs code
is highlighted by vs code itself
if i go back to what i just did type in
screencast
hitting command shift p to open the
command palette first
or f1
screencast is already recently used so
it's already
now would be off i want to switch it on
again
here we go so now if you
show all your crazy shortcuts you
customize and learn the new commands
that you have memorized
this will help to explain it much better
this is how obvious code comes out of
the box
so part one is we're looking at what are
kind of
the customizations that you can do to
make vs code
adapt better to your workflow to get the
tools you most
use most right in front of you and to
get just different styles that
everybody has in the development into
the tool we use most
outer box vs code comes with a lot of
amazing tools already
there's extensions for everything you
need under the moon and it's
a highly adaptable ui so the first part
already showed with a screencast mode
let's check
that first so we know it's on and i can
present what i'm doing
first off i love
autosave mode because i keep
trying to perfect my code and don't save
enough
and if i have autosave mode on i make
sure
to save often even though i don't hit
command
s or hit go into the menu
and then my build pipelines are from
setup to give me
an instant preview so i can actually
work on my code and keep coding away and
see
instantly what i'm doing so let's enable
that
we open settings move that to the right
and split pane
get a little bit more room and autosave
is actually the first option right on
top
to show you how to search you hit up
autosave within the command
and it actually shows you two options so
if i go from off
to after delay it will now save my file
every
every one second so going to this file
which isn't edited yet
if i comment something out
now i have it marked modified after a
second
if i edit edit again wait a second
it's now saved on focus change does the
same when you switch between taps
so if you finish it work in one file
switch to another
now the file is saved as well
if i move to
on window change now if i focus
out of this code and back in
things are being saved and
back in so now we have deletions and
modifications
all saved let's revert that switch back
and it's saved
what i recommend is after delay it's the
easiest
keeps your work saved you never lose it
and you keep seeing your changes as you
work
which is makes me feel productive at
least
next one up is how
we actually use the ui this code
has this left activity bar
and it's great you have search you have
source control
you have debugging and you can find your
extensions
what i don't like i often especially on
a smaller screen when i work on my
laptop
i want to hide and show the sidebar as
needed
because if i have the files open i don't
need to go in there
but that means probably one of
you who doesn't like that the windows
and everything moves around
so there's two cams sidebar on the left
and sidebar no right now when you close
it
my code stays put which is good
so you can move it anytime back and
there's a command going with that
toggle sidebar
you already see cyber visibility with i
have been using command b
and you can see toggle sidebar position
so let's move it back
so you can confuse you can follow along
on your own
vs code can do a lot more customizations
in the ui
very commonly is
dragging these icons around where you
need them
so you can move extensions up or down
but let's get a little more interesting
so let's open the terminal
and what i find a really good way
to bring things together where i look at
them at the same time
is moving for example the debug console
into the run and debug
activity bar view now they're in the
same spot
i can start debugging i can see my break
points i can see the debug log output
i might even be able to close this so i
have more room for my code
that's one way get away
um is search search
is really amazing in this small sidebar
for some quick
quick searches um you look around
you find your lines you're looking for
but i also like it down here
now if i go into search i actually do
have a lot more room
and can see the longer lines as well
so that's another way so bring a search
back
i can also bring for example the
problems view
over here so now as i go through my
problems
i can again maximize the space i need
so make the best of the room you have
on a small screen on a large screen
adapt it to whatever you need
but if you get into a weird spot
you can reset the view locations
and bring everything back where it was
what i like to do
to extend that i showed off search
and the panel below another way to use
search
is using it within the editor so we're
looking for
search mode
in your search mode and we switch that
to reuse editor
which means it will only open in the
other always using the same window
if you already have search open
now if we hit search command shift f
it opens over here so we can actually
reduce it remove it here
we don't need anymore we can always
access it
with the command if we need to or a
shortcut
if you search now you'll find that
it's okay you keep losing your search
results so now i just go back
my search go there over here so the
other
setting i recommend with that is search
double click behavior
in this case it's go to location which
is default
and open location to the side is what
brings the magic
so now they give to search some space i
can now actually browse
through my search results
which gave a lot of space in the editor
with all lines presented and they open
on the right side to let me use the code
so this is my favorite style of
searching
and it gives me this really nice
overview of the code
so let's look at word wrap because you
can see there's
a lot of things missing if you use vs
code in a small space
or with many split editors going back to
settings
word wrap is default of
envious code if you switch it on
that's the first option or the easiest
this code will break lines whenever
they hit the borders of the editor
which is really nice for smaller screens
just to make things fit especially if
you if you used to be writing longer
lines
like in documentation or markdown
the other way is word rep column
which then uses the word rep column
setting
which is set to 80 and it will just
break
on that so the editor window doesn't do
anything anymore
but it's just breaking on the 80
characters limit
the last option is bounded which is a
combination of both
it still uses the 80 limit 80 character
limit
to set the limit for each line
but you can also go in
and now we'll pick up the editor so
really useful to have
it's my default user to have it on so i
can see all the code without
scrolling left and right next up what's
really typical in my flow
is creating a lot of files to like to
create markdown files
so when you open a vs code onto a file
there's not much there and then you have
to pick the language mode down here
let's click mark down and now i can take
my notes
the other way to do this
is picking up
the default default
language mode
let's go up here default formatter
default language that's it
so default language mode is assigned to
every new file you create that's
untitled
so reset that to markdown
now each file we create will
automatically
be a markdown file
which is great for taking notes or just
scribbling down your to-do
the other option is setting it to
active ad editor language
which will pick up the latest the last
file
you have in index.js create a new file
will create an index.js file
open the function and everything is
already set to javascript and i can save
it wherever i need
if i am in an html file
i can continue creating more html files
really useful
and feels just right next up
you see i already created a lot of
different files i'm working on my
project
pin tabs was one of the most requested
features
that we had in our backlog
and it finally landed in the recent
releases
let me show you how it works in this
case
i'm working on app.js as my main project
and i keep clicking around in other
parts of the project
but i keep i don't want to lose app.js
i can just hit pin on that file
on a tab and now you see a little pin
appearing
and it's it will not not go away it will
always stay around
can't just close it similar to in the
browser
these tabs are made to stay
pin tabs has some really cool
customizations as well
pin tabs tabs
you can make them a little bit more
compact because this file is taking a
lot of space
in my tab bar all the time now compact
allows you to just limit it to the file
icon
and shrink will still show you the first
characters
so as you pin more files
you have still an idea of what's behind
them
i like this part especially this works
well for me now
so what else can i do to actually make
use of all these tabs i have opened
to see them we just recently
as well added wrap
tabs
if you enable it finally
all the files i have open and the tabs i
keep hoarding
are at my fingertips so i can close them
i can clean them up maybe i want to get
my space back
but this really allows you to remove
just need to scroll and go left and
right to refine things
so that plus pin tabs allows you to
really get on top of your tab hoarding
so we customize the ui we customized
tabs
we really improved our productivity and
now i really don't want to lose those
changes
the way to do that to not just back your
changes
up but also bring them on all the other
bs code machines like your personal one
and you work one and your vms
you can use settings sync
it's built into vs code so nothing else
to install
just go into the menu here turn on
settings sync
it will ask you which pieces of your
customizations you want to
bring in i want to bring everything you
sign in
you pick the channel i'm on insiders so
i'm not gonna pick that you can have
both
installed site by site and sync
differently
i'm gonna pick my github account you can
also pick your microsoft login
and now this code uploads
everything that i customized
onto my account
and it's turned on any changes that i
made
like the settings everything else
is now securely backed up and i can
bring into the next vs code instance
this is a fresh vs code installation
that has nothing set up look at the
settings
it's empty nothing happened here
i want to get my changes in so in this
instance as well turn on settings sync
select everything pick insiders
github accounts save to my system now it
will get
oop everything in it's already there
what happened
so now if i customize further here let's
pick a color theme
maybe in today i'm in the mood for some
more
red and
let's keep working over here
settings extensions everything will be
synchronized
across uvs code and it's always one type
away
next up let's look at intellisense
and javascript debugging one of the most
useful things on a day-to-day while
using vs code
and how we can make it even easier with
the right shortcuts
and the right settings first off expand
and shrink selection
this shortcut and you're in screencast
mode
is one of the most powerful to navigate
your elements quickly pressing
ctrl shift left and right
allows you to go from your current
selection
expanding it and shrinking it back
to the next expression up and down this
works great
in html to get the whole tag
or just a part of the attribute
the whole tag the parent parent element
and then going up to the whole document
and all the way back
in javascript it works the same way
you can select the current word the
current object
the current function call and all the
way
up and down one
special trick it works in markdown
expanding here we'll select the current
code block then going up to the next
header
this way you can quickly navigate even
within markdown
giving the that vs code knows a lot
about your code
the next trick we have powered up is
intellisense
the insert mode if i go for example
in the router intellisense
command space is what powers
this autocomplete i go back on a router
i will see all
the methods on the express router
if i now go in and hit delete
it will insert the value
going into settings searching for
suggest
insert such as insert mode
you have the editor suggest insert mode
let's switch it to replace by default
which i feel more intuitive it does
delete the text which is why
insert is the default so you don't lose
any of your
text now if i start with the old get
i can now go back pick this
what about
just post now this function is replaced
we can do the same in other elements
get element by id i could replace it
with get elements by tag name
and the whole thing so you can go back
and forth
and expand and reduce what you're
looking for
if it's just a simple rename select it
how do you find out that this exists
does the other
suggest status bar
which is a neat addition to
the suggestion box that's popping up
now vs code will tell you how to do
replace which is the default
and how to toggle over to an insert now
if i have
the get root note i press command
enter it will actually do the old way of
the insert which i switched off
you can also show more it's especially
useful
for web functionality control space
you can see the very rich documentation
for
css html and javascript that comes baked
in
but for all the rich typescript
annotations that your code has
you can also resize those if you need
more space
or less space on a small screen i love
to have those
it's a little bigger the next feature
area
i'd like to share some tips and tricks
for is the javascript debugger
that comes built in with vs code last
year
the team launched a new version and has
a few tricks up its sleeves that make it
really easy to set up without doing the
whole launch to adjacent dance
and getting the team on boarded the
first way
to debug any script that you already
have defined in your package or json
is this code lens that gets added to
the file hit debug
start this will launch a javascript
debug terminal
for you with the script executing
now the script is running and my server
is up i can open a browser
that shows the output my beautiful app
now the debugging is running i can go
into my server side code
set breakpoints
refresh and debug everything
i like to know about if i step over this
now the image path set i can edit things
which is the amazing part of debugging
and continue now when at the button the
cat is replaced
by a dog which is how it should be
refishing again without the break point
we have the old cat back
this is one way the other way is
launching a javascript debug terminal on
your own
if you kill this terminal go
into the command palette search for
javascript debug terminal
and get this it's opens up
in the terminal panel but now every node
script
you execute from here will be launched
in debug mode
even just a simple file and script like
this that doesn't even have a package or
json
i can now launch set a breakpoint in
hit note hello dot js
and start debugging while you debug
everything that happens will be printed
to the
debug console so now continue i will see
the
world output here so you get logging
and debugging all in one combined within
vs code so no context switching
the other way to launch
let's use the same let's use the same
debug terminal
for our app we knew we had a breakpoint
here before
if we just hit npm start now
same thing will happen all the node
processes are launched
are being inspected and running in the
debugger
if we now reload the app
or again pause we can now again just
like in the browser go to debug console
and inspect the state of the app
now it's undefined stepping one back in
it's again defined we can poke around at
all the little
things that are running within the app
we can expand the objects and everything
else happening within the debug console
the best trick what i find that really
connects it all
it's not just going from the server side
but also going to the client side as
well
now that the app is running it prints
out where it's running
so if i launch this
link it will open chrome
with the debugger connected
i'm going to remove this breakpoint so
you have loads
now we have the app running in the
browser and
[Music]
this file which is running in the
browser is running in debug mode
if i set a breakpoint here i can now
inspect the state of everything of the
world
with envious code again
go to debug console see what is power
toggled
i can change power toggled
really screw up the state of the world
move the breakpoint continue
now oh yeah no
i want it but makes the point
let's fix it again set the breakpoint
hit the button
so reset for toggled
and continue the other way to go about
it
and this bridges the gap to console
logging is adding log points
paw is
toggled now hit
enter this is a log point and every time
again the browser
when this code runs it will not break
and pause
but actually just print the statement
and the expression i added i find a new
javascript debugger amazing
any app i run i run it through vs code
so anytime i run into an issue i have
something i need to clarify within the
code
i can just add a lock point or a
breakpoint and do whatever i need to do
to get to the root cause of it for me
that's a lot easier than sprinkling in
console logs and occasionally forgetting
one when i commit it
so try it out hopefully you like it too
now that our app is running and the
debugger attached i can show you the
last and probably most amazing part
of the new infrastructure it's really
important
to make things fast for your app not
just in the back end where you serve the
data
and serve the pages but also in the
front end where things have to
be responsive for the user to actually
click on
looking at my app i created this slash
data endpoint that takes a while
to serve this really important business
data
looking at the app
there's the code let's find out why is
it slow
to start profiling we have to look at
the call stack
within the run and debug menu and then
see the take performance profile button
on the left little circle
with a dot inside take performance
profile is also the
command that you can look up and may be
assigned to a hotkey
let's start profiling this
one the node.js process
for about 10 seconds go back
to server hit it with requests
refresh a few times as soon as the 10
seconds are over
vs code will serve us with the profile
profiles by default sorted by self time
which shows you the function first
that does the most computing in this
case
it's merge.js the other aggregate is
total time
which also includes all the leaf nodes
of that function and everything it calls
into
so going to merge we can actually go in
this is called by merge sort
and the novice function and doing some
more
processing so let's look at the function
itself within vs code
you will get a code lens that shows
the profiling layer we collected in the
context of the function
for app.js this also shows forget data
with self time and total time
showing here that this function itself
was really fast
but overall in total it called some
really expensive functions
the other way to monitor is using the
real-time performance
let's give it some room and we can see
this real-time performance graph
which is provided by an extension
install the vs code.js profile flame
extension which adds this panel
to the run and debug panel
now we see cpu and heap let's give it
something to do
we can see the cpu usage is going up to
100 percent
and the heap because of gc is also going
up
and that you see it's happening and
things are lower again the same
works on the front end now if we go into
the call stack
and select the browser
we'll get even more data now we can
monitor
going back to our original page
we can monitor dom nodes and layouts
and style recalculations on an ongoing
basis
monitoring how fast or front-end is and
what potentially could cause issues
i'm excited for how easy this makes it
to work on performance as you do your
day-to-day coding
not just for your back end but also your
front end and
all in one interface
that was it thanks so much for watching
i hope you have a blast adding these
tips and tricks
to your daily routine with vs code
follow us on twitter and techtalk
for even more tips and tricks and keep
checking out the release notes that we
put out on a monthly basis
for any new additions that might help
you i'm herald kirchner
thanks so much from the vs co team bye